Willkommen zum Podcast UFO, hier sind Ihre Gastgeber Florentin Will und Steffefefefefan Titzler. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast Podcast UFO, Florentin will mir Stefan Tietze. Ich habe dich, als du gerade reingelaufen bist, du bist wahnsinnig nervös, muss man sagen, du bist wahnsinnig aufgedreht, dein Fuss ist im Gips, der andere Fuss ist im schönen Birkenstocklatschen, also wirklich grösser könnte der Unterschied nicht sein zwischen deinen beiden Füssen schon alleine, aber du schaust auch generell so eine grosse Unruhe aus. Trotzdem habe ich gemerkt, ich habe dich sehr vermisst. Ah, das freut mich. Ich habe dich wirklich vermisst. Ich habe dich auch vermisst. Man erfährt ja viel von dir, ich habe das Interview gelesen mit dir in der Zeitung, hat mir total gut gefallen. Das freut mich immer. Und wir sind in dieser Phase unserer Freundschaft angekommen, wo man nicht mehr miteinander redet, sondern nur noch über Interviews kommuniziert. und ich den Treffer und so, ach ja, du hast jetzt ein Pferd? Ah, okay. Ja, klar. Ich weiß, dass du noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen hast. Ja, ja. Nee, das stimmt schon. Man erfährt sehr viel aus der Presse voneinander. Ich habe auch sehr viel über Dritte erfahren, was mit dem Fuss passiert ist. Ja, ich habe meinen Zeh gebrochen an all die, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben. Es war ein heißer Ritt, es war eine heisse Reise und ich habe viel nachgedacht über mich und meinen Körper. Du hast deinen Zeh gebrochen. Welchen Zeh? Der kleine Zeh des rechten Fußes. Erstmal, ich finde, das ist wahnsinnig viel Aufwand für den gebrochenen kleinen Zeh. Alles, was du da am Fuß hast, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Ich habe gehört, Fun Facts, dass man den gebrochenen Zeh ca. sieben Mal im Leben bricht und die meisten Menschen wissen davon gar nicht, wenn der bricht, weil es ja auch irgendwie scheißegal ist. Der kleine Zeh hängt ja nur noch da dran, das ist ja nur noch ein Überblöpsel der Evolution. Ich habe tatsächlich diesen Fakt in verschiedensten Ausformungen auch bekommen. Und das ist ganz interessant zu sehen, weil es gibt ja so dieses Urban Myth und so und Sachen, die man sich sagt. Und in dem Moment, in dem du in der Öffentlichkeit sagst, ich habe mir ein Zeh gebrochen, kriegst du 20 Nachrichten und eine eine heißt, 50 Prozent der Leute brechen sich einmal im Leben den C, ohne zu merken, nächste Nachricht, 80 Prozent aller Menschen brechen sich einmal den C und dann jeder dritte und alles sind andere Daten oder manchmal auch so wie du, jeder Mensch brecht sich zweimal, siebenmal habe ich schon gesagt, jeder Mensch brecht sich siebenmal. Ich muss auch sagen, ich verändere aber auch Zahlen zugunsten der Story, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist mir mittlerweile völlig egal. Zahlen sind völlig egal. Als ob jemand, wenn man sagt, 50% brechen sich den C oder 30% Leute sagen, ach 30, das ist ja gar nichts. So ist das scheißegal. Ich erzähle auch nichts mehr, wo ich das Gefühl habe, das muss gegenüber auch im Gegner. Ich nehme Gesprächspartner als Gegner wahr, unter freuter Versprecher. Aber ich habe oft... Ich will immer so Mindblowing, Mindblown erzeugen. Und das erreicht mir nicht. 30% reichen mir nicht. Ich muss zu härteren Geschützen greifen. Aber ich bin sehr selten in politischen Diskussionen verfangen. Extrem selten. Und wenn, dann will ich so schnell wieder raus. Wenn, dann will ich so schnell es geht raus. Aber du hast einen gebrochenen C, kommst du nicht so schnell weg. Aber manchmal denke ich mir, ich habe jetzt eine Statistik. Keine Ahnung, Kriminalität in Deutschland hat sich so und so verändert.
Du weisst, sie ist gesunken und du wusstest auch mal die Prozentzahl irgendwas und jetzt du denkst dir, ich weiss, dass es gesunken ist, aber ich weiss nicht wie viel, nimm 15 Prozent, nimm einfach 15 Prozent. Also du weisst, weil du, du kannst ja nicht sagen, die Go to 15. Immer 15.
Für meinen Geschmack ein bisschen zu rund die Zahl noch. Es klingt ausgedacht immer. Es klingt aber... 15 Prozent, so du weißt, weil du kannst ja nicht sagen, die go to 15.
Immer 15? Für meinen Geschmack ein bisschen zu rund die Zahl noch.
Es klingt ausgedacht immer, es klingt aber nicht zu aufgerundet wie 20 Prozent. Genau, das ist nämlich das, was ich meine. Wenn du sagst 14 Prozent, sagen die Leute, ah ja, jetzt komm, 14, als ob man das so genau bemessen könnte. Wenn du sagst 20, hm. Ja, zu genau, zu gerundet. 15 ist so, hast auf- oder abgerundet, aber zumindest nicht so sehr, dass du die Zahl drastisch veränderst, wie auf 20 oder 30. Das stimmt schon. Ich finde, die Go-To-15 ist eine gute Idee. Das ist immer so dieses Problem, wenn man Dinge nur zu 85 Prozent weiss. So, du weisst sie, aber die letzten 15 Prozent fehlen. Dann denkst du dir, soll ich jetzt die 85 Prozent, die ich weiss, die Tonne treten oder soll ich die zumindest noch mal raushauen? Hast du das Gefühl, dass dir immer 15 Prozent fehlen? Mir fehlen mindestens immer 35 Prozent. Also ich habe tatsächlich entweder null oder 85. Ich habe immer null und die Leute reden gerade über ein Thema und ich weiß, ich bin so kurz davor, den entscheidenden Fakt zu wissen, aber das Ding fehlt mir. Mir fehlen oft Görder. Irgendjemand wurde umgebracht, aber ich kenne den Namen nicht. Und dann gibt es immer so diese Umformulierungen, der wurde doch dieser Journalist umgebracht. Und man klingt dann so, ja, wage, the vague man. Ja, und bei mir ist es auch immer so, dass das eine wichtige Wort fehlt, so Ombudsmann, so dass ein Wort was fehlt oder Namen fehlen. Der Name fehlt immer. Name fehlt immer und so und dann wird es immer so eine vage Geschichte, an der niemand mehr Spaß hat. Ja. Aber deswegen finde ich diese, das kann man sich mal irgendwie in den Podcast-Ufotrivia aufnehmen, zur 21 Grad Regel, weil man kurze Hose tragen sollte, die ich aber auch schon wieder revidiert habe, könnt ihr in einer anderen Folge nachhören. Die Revision, der Artikel zur Revision ist länger als der eigentliche Artikel. Und kommt jetzt die 15%, die Go-To-15%, das finde ich sehr gut. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wenn ihr nicht weiter wisst, geht es zu 15%. Total. Und ja, ich habe mir ein Zeh gebrochen, bin schön gegen die Tür gerannt. Und es ist so merkwürdig, weil ich bin völlig immun gegen alles, bin unzerstörbar, ich hatte noch nie irgendwas, ich war noch nie im Krankenhaus außer bei der Geburt, haha, aber ansonsten noch nie im Krankenhaus. Wie, haha. Das ist ein Comedy- ich muss aber ein paar Gags machen, die links und rechts. Sorry. Und so.
Und dann denkst du dir halt... Das ist ja auch ein Stand-up-Comedian, der die ganze Zeit Gags macht und dann immer, aber das so abtut mit ha ha und das Publikum weiss immer nicht, weil das lachen soll, weil alle Gags immer so als ha ha abgestempelt wurden weil nach jeder Pointe kommt so ein lakonisches ha ha ha ha ha so, nächstes Thema und ich war noch nie im Krankenhaus und dann hast du diesen C, der wirklich im 45-Grad-Winkel absteht. Ah, Abstand, das wollte ich noch fragen. Also ich bin richtig dagegen gewemst. Du wichst nicht wie jemand, der ins Krankenhaus geht, ehrlich gesagt. Genau, genau. Und ein Fuchs geht nicht ins Krankenhaus, haben wir eh damals erfolgreich rausgearbeitet. Und dann denkst du dir so, was braucht man alles im Krankenhaus? Und dann habe ich mir wirklich so einen Rucksack gemacht. Kulturtäschchen. Und ich habe mitgenommen eine Flasche Wasser, mein Kindel. Das ist ja das letzte mitgebrachte Wasser, warst du doch da. Nee, ich will immer Wasser dabei haben. Immer Wasser, je, man kann es da. Er klopft auf seinen Rucksack. Immer Wasser dabei. Ach, Wasserflaschen, Lugen raus. Immer Wasser dabei haben. Und dann bin ich ins Krankenhaus gefahren und ich konnte ja, ich hatte ja meinen Zeh, der stand ja wirklich weg. Das heißt, ich konnte keinen Schuh anziehen. Aber du hast ja nie wirklich geflossene Schuhe an. Aber was macht man jetzt? Ich konnte meine Sandalen auch nicht anziehen, aber guter Punkt, kommen wir gleich noch dazu. Freu dich drauf. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, ich muss barfuß gehen, weil ich kann keine Schuhe anziehen und ich kann jetzt auch keinen Socken anziehen, sondern bin ich barfuß ins Krankenhaus gelaufen und dann stand ich in der Rezeption und hieß es erstmal ja Krankenkassenkarte. Ah ja, ich habe einen Rucksack dabei mit einem Buch, Snacks, Wasserflaschen, ich habe ein interessantes Buch dabei, keine Versicherungskarte, stand, aber das ist halt so die Situation, wie man es sich vorstellt, in so einem Warteraum. Stell dir vor, du hättest die TK-Safe-Funktion, die TK-Krankassen-App. Die hätte ich in dem Moment gebraucht.
Bringen Sie mich ins Krankenhaus. Und es war genauso wie bei den Simpsons, wo man zum Arzt geht und dann sitzen da drei Leute. Alle gelb. Der eine hat so einen Pfeil in der Schulter, der andere hat so einen Tiger am Arm und der andere hat so einen riesigen Beuler auf dem Kopf. Und genau so stand ich da mit meinem gebrochenen, winzigen, roten, knallblauen, angeschwommenen Zähnen. Ich hasse das, wenn Leute dich sofort durchschauen. Richtig. Ich bin gerne ein Mysterium, ich bin gerne komplex. Wenn du in einem Raum sitzt und alle sehen sofort einen Zähnchen. Genau. Oh, blöd. Anders als bei den Simpsons sah das Wartezimmer nicht so aus. Da saßen drei ganz normale Menschen, wo man sagt, so wie so eine Gameshow, so, wer von denen hat ein orthopädisches Problem? Hättest du nicht geschafft. Hättest du auch nicht geschafft, Stefan. Nee, wäre Durchfall. Kommt einfach, brecht ein Durchfall. Und ich bin dann halt, der Aufzug war ausgefallen, perfekt, das heißt, ich bin diese Marmortreppe hochgegangen, also wie so eine Ente, halt so, weil ich konnte ja nicht meinen Vorderfuß abrollen, das heißt, ich musste immer so watscheln. Ja, Watschelgang. Und das heißt, ich bin da watschelnd barfuss, also man hat mich schon kommen hören. Mit einem Taucher. Und alle so, was kommt da jetzt? Und dann komme ich da rein, mit meinem verkrüppelten Zeh, komme da rein und dann hieß es Krankenkassenkarte und ich so, wir sehen uns gleich nochmal und ich watschel wieder raus. Du hast es vergessen zu Hause. Ich dachte eher, du hast es einfach nicht, weil du wirkst auch wie jemand, der keine Krankenkassenkarte haben könnte. Ja, die Geschichte ist an der Stelle noch viel länger, aber ich weiss nicht, wie interessant das ist, weil tatsächlich hatte ich keine Krankenkassenkarte. Ach so. Und dann rufe ich meine Versicherung an und duicherung an und du bist aber dann, was ist denn wenn du Autounfall hast? Stefan. Die behandelt dich doch, wenn du eine Krankenkarte hast. Ich bin ein Bürokratiewrack. Freak. Ich habe nichts. Ich habe gar nichts. Und wenn mich, und das Problem ist, und das deswegen, und da möchte ich jetzt gleich mal zu dir kommen, so arrogante Arschlöcher wie du machen es Leuten wie mir schwierig. Weil wenn du dich, sagen wir mal, du hast dich die ersten fünf Jahre deines Lebens nicht um deine Krankenversicherung gekümmert. Es kommt dieser Punkt, ab dem man es nicht mehr machen kann. Das sind doch Fragen unangenehm. Genau, du kannst auch jetzt, ich bin jetzt 28, falls ich jetzt mal jemanden frage, wie bügelt man eigentlich? Zu spät, die Leute denken, wie? Ja, vor allem nicht, ich habe mir eine Baschmaschine gekauft. Ja, genau. Dann kommen Fragen, wie hast du bislang überlebt? Und genau so ist es so, angenommen, du merkst, okay, ich bin 28 und ich weiß nicht, ob und wo ich versichert bin. Und dann, so, dann dachte ich, ich wäre bei einer Versicherung versichert. Ruf da an, sag, mein Name ist Valentin Will, könnten Sie irgendwie bitte bei dem Arzt anrufen und sagen, dass ich hier versichert bin? Ja, Name bitte. Sie sind ja nicht versichert. Aha, dann wünsche ich Ihnen an der Stelle noch ein ganz schönes Leben. Schönen Vormittag. Ein schönes Restleben, hätte ich gesagt. Schönes Restleben, wir werden wahrscheinlich nie wieder miteinander sprechen. Und an der Stelle lege ich auf und sage Tschüss und dann stehst du da und denkst, weil auch die Person am Telefon muss sich denken, was ist das für ein Vormittag? Vollidiot. Naja, ich habe es über Riesenumwege hingekriegt und ich stand da rum. Du willst beim Callcenter auch nicht das Telefonat sein, wo in der Pause darüber gesprochen wird. Nee. Du willst, und das warst du. Das bin ich oft. Ja, das bist du oft und das willst du nicht sein. Du willst, weil die kriegen ja so viele Verrückte an, dem ja alles gehört in dem Leben. Vor allem da, wo ich angerufen habe, das war nicht meine Versicherung. Das ist irgend so ein komisches Zwischending. Ergo. Das ist eine irgendwie Sozialversicherung oder irgendwie so etwas anderes, aber keine Krankenversicherung. Ich weiß, wie du anrufst. Ich genau weiß, wie du das... Und ja, und dann... Das hab ich aber schon mal gesagt. Ich hab doch keine Ahnung von so einem Scheiß... Und jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo du unsympathisch wirst. Genau dieser Shame, den du gerade vollführst, sorgt dafür, dass Leute wie ich sich nicht darum kümmern, weil sie Angst haben und anrufen und sagen, hallo, ich bin jetzt 72, was ist eine Versicherung? Mal kurz die drei Eckpunkte. Was sind Steuern? Genau so, jetzt mal angenommen, ich wüsste nicht, was Steuern sehr. Genauso ist es auch. Und schon die Handschellen. Und er ist lächerlich und du rufst an und sagst, nicht nur sind sie nicht bei uns versichert, wir sind keine Versicherung. Ja, schrecklich. Auf jeden Fall, irgendwann hat es, und vor allem, dann habe ich mit der Rezeptionsfrau gesprochen und die meinte, ja auch eine Versicherungskarte behandeln wir sie nicht. Und ich so, Entschuldigung, mein C ist knallblau und der fällt gleich ab. Der steht ab in 50, gerade war es noch 45 Grad, mittlerweile 50 Grad Winkel. Da bin ich nach Hause gefahren und habe wirklich gegoogelt, selber versorgen, halt so, was kann man auch ohne einen Arzt machen, weil ich traue Ärzten nicht. Ich glaube, viele Sachen kann man auch selber machen, so dann auch so Schulter einkugeln, dann läufst du halt mal gegen die Wand, so passt schon. Was ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann mit einem kleinen Zeh? Den brauchst du ja nicht unbedingt. Eben. Das ist ja dein Testzeh. Da kannst du ja mal rumprobieren. Ja, hat nicht geklappt. Und das Problem war, und deswegen ist es auch anders, als du gesagt hast, mit den Zehen, die man sich regelmäßig bricht. Das Problem war, dass er nicht nur gebrochen war, sondern auch verschoben. Also gebrochen. Und dann stell dir so vor, dass er so seitlich daneben rutscht. Also dass er so angewinkelt ist. Und dann kann er nicht mehr zusammenheilen. Oder er w so zusammen wieder. Oder er wächst so zusammen, da kann ich nie wieder Schuhe tragen. Müsste den Rest meines Lebens ... Oder so Besonderanfertigungsschuhe, wenn man so ein kleiner Zipfel rausschaut, so ein Fenster. Vor allem, es sah ganz witzig aus, weil mein Fuss hat halt konstant Toes-up gegeben. Ja. Es war immer so, wenn man meinen Fuss gefragt hätte, wie geht's dir, hätte er ein falsches Bild gegeben, weil er sagt Toe ab, aber knallblau. Und er wurde nicht behandelt, betäubt und dann habe ich diesen Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh bekommen. Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh? Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh, es ist der Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh. Und weil ich darf meinen Vorderfuss nicht abrollen. Das habe ich mir fast gesagt im Namen erschliessen können. So, und dann den bekommen und es war furchtbar, weil auch, das war dann so dieses Ding, und dann bin ich auch zu diesem Laden gegangen, die so dieses ganze orthopädische Zeug verkaufen. Und dann so, ja, ich brauche einen Vorderfuß-Entlassungsschuh. Und dann geht die Verkäuferin zu so einer Box und reißt die Box auf, gibt mir den Schuh und ich so, ja, aber ich bin nicht versichert. Und sie so, jetzt habe ich die Box schon aufgerissen. Oh nein, die Box aufgerissen. Und ich so so, ja. Weil, denn da muss mehrere Vorderfußentlassungsschuhe. Einer, ein Vorderfußentlassungsschuh pro Box. Pro Box? Ja! Das Verhältnis von Box, von Vorderfußentlassungsschuh, Box zu Vorderfußentlassungsschuh, Anzahl stimmt nicht überein. Und ich glaube, der ist beidfüssig. Und Schuhe kannst du doch perfekt, ah, kann sein. Ich glaube, der ist beidfüssig, das ist nämlich das Ding. Das Beste an Schu doch, die zu stapeln, einanderzulegen, so jing und jang. Vor allem, ich habe wirklich sehr wenige Erfahrungen mit Krankengeschichten. Darf ich den behalten? Nein. Wobei, ich habe auch noch zu Hause Krücken, ehrlich gesagt. Oder was macht man damit? Also der, den ich bekommen habe, war brandneu. Das heißt, ich gehe davon aus, dass jeder brandneu ist, der einen bekommt, weil warum sollten manche... Also ich bin unterste Linie, ich habe keine Versicherung, das heißt, ich kriege das Schlechtes vom Schlechten. Also wenn ich keine Gebrauchten kriege, kriegt niemand Gebrauchten. Aber sie sieht schon sehr bequem aus. Ich finde die auch so schön, die mal so zu haben einfach. Also, naja, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass irgendwo, wenn man mal falsch abbiegt, bei der Autobahn oder so, dass man auf so einer grossen Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh-Halde vorbeikommt, wo die alle liegen.
So der grosse Friedhof. Weißt du, wie grauenvoll ist das, wenn man den nicht mehr benutzt? Den trägst du jetzt drei Wochen oder so? Und das ist also das Ding, weil ich habe ja zum Beispiel, ich habe ja auch von meiner Zahnspange habe ich noch die Plättchen. So, die habe ich noch. Warum hast du die denn noch? Weil die aus Gold sind. Und dann habe ich die bekommen. Und ich weiß nicht, auch eine andere Geschichte, ich habe meine Zahnspange lange gehabt, zwei Jahre, und die sind aus Gold, diese Plättchen, weil die sind innen. Und Gold ist ja ein sehr weiches Metall und dadurch scheuert das nicht die Zunge auf, weil wenn das ein härteres Metall wäre, würde das die Zunge aufscheuern. Ja. Und deswegen war das Gold sehr weich. Und dann haben mir die... Das Gold ist ja, naja. Nee, deswegen, wenn man Olympia-Gewinner, beißen ja auch manchmal in die Goldmedaille. Warum? Weil man in Gold ein Stück beißen kann. Man kann einen kleinen Zahnabdruck auf Goldmedaillen machen, wenn es echtes Gold ist. Und so kann man prüfen, ob es echtes Gold ist. Cool. Tja, keine Versicherung, aber ich kenne mich jetzt auf die Quiz-Duell-Frage. Und dann habe ich, als sie mir die Zahnsperre herausmontiert haben, habe ich mal so gefragt, was passiert mit dem Gold?
Was passiert denn mit dem Gold? Wir haben gerade fünf Hände in dem Mund.
Ich will mal ein Gold haben!
Ja, sie bekommen ja ihr Gold.
Und dann haben die so ein bisschen ertappt geguckt.
Ah, okay.
Und dann dachte ich, und dann die so ein bisschen ertappt geguckt.
Und dann dachte ich, und dann die so, ja, das kriegen sie natürlich.
Und ich dachte mir, wenn ich nicht gefragt hätte.
Und deswegen denke ich mir auch so, ich habe ja dann diesen Vorderfußentlastungsschuh.
Und ich denke mir dann den Rest meines Lebens, wenn ich mir schon was breche, dann bitte noch mal den kleinen Zeh, weil wenn man die Heilmethoden schon
hat. Ach Gott, den hebst du auf?
Ich werf den doch nicht weg.
Nee, aber du kannst dir doch so eine Altkleidersammlung
geben oder sowas.
So die Kinder in Afrika, jeder kriegt so eine
Box. Was hast du? Ein T-Shirt!
Ein Gute-Arbeit-Riginess-T-Shirt.
Und du? Ich hab ein Gürtel.
Und du? Ich hab einen Vorderfuß, einen Entlastungsschuhe für den rechten Fuss. Klong, klong. Und den linken Fuss. Muss jeden Tag 50 Kilometer zur Schule laufen, klong, aber mit super entlasteten Vorderfüssen. Ohne Witz, mein Vorderfuss war doch nie so entlastet. Das kann ich nicht glauben. Er sieht auch sehr warm aus. Vor allem, es ist ja ganz geil, wenn man ein Körperteil Urlaub machen kann. Der Körper ist ja wie so ein Oktopus, so alles ist ständig in Bewegung. Und manchmal hat man aber, aber der Mensch ja nicht, der Mensch ist nicht immer in Bewegung, der hat manchmal Urlaub. Und so kann auch manchmal ein Körperteil Urlaub haben. Ich finde, es gibt nichts besseres als Krankenhäuser. Steuere These, aber Krankenhaushausaufenthalte sind... Friedhöfe sind bei mir knappe zwei. Ja, auch unterschätzt, aber ich liebe Krankenhäuser. Kernkraftwerk auf drei, ganz klar. Ehrlich gesagt, es gibt doch keinen schöneren Ort, um... Ich finde es so toll, im Krankenhaus operiert zu werden und ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus zu sitzen. Das ist das Beste, was es gibt. Alle, also dir kann nichts passieren, weil wenn was passiert, sind sehr viele Ärzte in unmittelbarer Nähe. Alle kümmern sich darum, du hast den geregelten, du musst dir über nichts Sorgen machen, du hast den geregelten Tagesablauf, du kriegst Essen, du musst dir um nichts Sorgen machen, ausser darum, wie du die Zeit rumbekommst. Und das ist doch total schön, du kannst lesen, du kannst Fernsehen gucken, du kannst irgendwie ein Spiel spielen, du kannst surfen im Internet.
Du hast einfach keine Verantwortung.
Du hast einfach nur das freieste Leben.
Du kannst machen, was du willst.
Es gibt aber unterschiedliche Ärzte und bei manchen fühle ich mich wohl als bei anderen.
Und es ist nur meine persönliche Meinung, bei denen, wo ich mich am allerunwohlsten fühle, sind so Sportärzte.
So super krass durchtrainierte, wo du weißt, der hat schon irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Oliver Kahn oder so da gehabt und hat denen schon Tipps gegeben oder irgendwie sowas. Hat den wieder fit gekriegt. Wieder aufgepäppelt nach 92. Und du kommst da halt so angedackelt und der hat halt, entlässt halt gerade irgendwie so einen Eishockey-Profi und sagst so, ja, ja, pass auf, irgendwie da, wenn du nochmal ein Schläger ins Gesicht kriegst und so, ja, wird schon, wird schon,, he he, und dann kommst du rein und sagst so, ja, ich bin gegen die Tür gerannt, du hast meinen kleinen Zeh gebrochen und der so, ach Gott, mein Gott, beim Eishockey spielen oder was, äh, nee, nee, gegen die Tür, ach so, diese kleine Tür, wie man auf die Eisfläche kommt, der dagegen gerannt, nee, in meiner Wohnung einfach eine normale Tür, ich bin kurz, nach dem Training einfach, nee, ich wollte Müsli essen. Ach so, ein bisschen Stärken oder was? Hab ein Turnier gehabt oder was? Grosses Spiel? Nee, einfach nee, nee, so Frühstück halt. Ah, wichtiges Frühstück, Training am Vormittag? Nee, es war das dritte Frühstück, also einfach, ich hatte noch Bock auf Snacks. Ach krass, richtig Massephase oder was? Nee, einfach Faul-Dansen, ein bisschen Snacken, ein bisschen, ne. Okay. Es tut echt weh auch so. Es tut echt leid, also es ist schon sehr schmerzhaft. Na, der vorhin, der drin war, der hat direkt hier den Eishockey-Schläger ins Gesicht, alle Zähne raus, sämtliche Zähne verschluckt, komplettes Kinn verschluckt, habe ich gerade komplett zusammengeflickt hier. Der geht heute noch raus und holt Gold. Ich gehe heute noch raus und tue, ich habe noch, ich habe noch Wasser, Kerrygold oder Pommersche, die mag ich ganz gerne. Dann ziehen Sie sich mal aus. Obenrum? Alles. Alles? Vor allem Füsse sind ja eine sehr sensible Zone. Nee. Und doch. Füsse? Ja. Klar. Die sind doch zum Gehen gemacht, auf allem Gehen. Soll das in deinem nächsten SZ-Interview stehen, Füsse sind zum Gehen gemacht? Füsse sind doch zum Gehen gemacht. Der neue Bestseller von Stefan T. Stefan in Klammern aufgebracht. Füße sind doch zum Gehen gemacht. Vor allem, also da merkt man, was man für ein Mensch ist. Zeh gebrochen, du fährst ins Krankenhaus und du denkst dir, vielleicht soll ich meine Zehennägel schneiden. Und ich habe wirklich noch meine Zehennägel geschnitten, weil ich mir dachte, na ja, da merkt man einfach, wie eitel man ist. Und dann fährt man hin und die Orthopädin erstmal schaut sich den Fuss an, es ist halt einfach saukitzelig so. Und du denkst dir, klar, Schmerz und so, aber halt auch, hm, nicht. Oh, nicht. Oh, lassen Sie es mal. Und sie so, tut es weh und ich so, nee, ja, es tut echt weh. Furchtbar. Und am Ende hat es funktioniert und die hat halt wirklich an diesem kleinen Zeh gezogen mit ihrer ganzen Kraft. Und es war halt so eine so eine knallharte Russin. Die hat halt wirklich in Stalingrad schon Rotarmisten wieder zusammengeflickt und jetzt hier und muss halt den kleinen C. Und die hat wirklich daran gezogen, als würde sie gerade irgendwie so ein Tauziehen-Wettbewerb. Aber wurde erst geröntgt, ne? Erst geröntgt, röntgt und da auch lustiger Zufall. Ich habe mein Buch mitgenommen, wie gesagt, da saß ich halt vor diesem Röntgenraum mit noch zwei anderen Leuten. Und ich wusste halt, die beiden sind mir dran, das heißt es dauert ein bisschen, das heißt ich habe angefangen mein Buch zu lesen und ich habe erst später gemerkt, dass es für den Außenstehenden durchaus ulkig gewirkt haben musste, denn ich saß da so mit meinem Buch und das Buch, das ich gelesen habe, war Radioaktivität und Gesundheit. Ich habe halt genau das Buch gelesen und mir ist es nicht aufgefallen, weil das hat mir, ich habe in Moin Moin mal gesagt, dass ich keine Ahnung von Radioaktivität habe und da hat mir jemand dieses Buch geschickt und ich dachte, man kann nicht lesen und es ist halt so cool, so vor dem Röntgenraum, die gesundheitlichen Einflüsse von Radioaktivität und ich so, mhm, mhm. Lächerlich gut vorbereitet auch für alle Situationen. Und jetzt einfach so, okay, der ist ein bisschen skeptisch.
Einfach so.
Das ist wirklich perfekt. Das ist ja wirklich grossartig. Es war wirklich das perfekte Buch für den perfekten Moment. Unglaublich, wie gut vorbereitet alle dachten, dass du willst, oder vor allem schlachten auch, wahrscheinlich haben die neben dir gedacht, warum hat er so ein Broschürenbuch bekommen? Genau, warum? Und die haben da so ein Aufklärungsbuch. Gucken so rein, so ein Bild von so Strahlenverbrennung. Und dann neben dir halt so Harry Potter und der Feuerkelch und denkt auch, ich bin so schlecht vorbereitet für diese Situation. Das könnte nicht schlechter. Und jemand fliegt so ein Drache drum und er sagt so, score. Wer lacht jetzt? Genau. Naja, das ist wirklich super. Und Röntgen macht echt Spass, ich Ich liebe geröntgen. Röntgen, Röntgen, ich weiß auch nicht, dass die deutsche Sprache noch irgendwann vorbei ist. Es macht so Spaß. Das ist auch ein Nachname, ne? Röntgen, der heißt Röntgen, der Mann. Da muss man auch mal sagen, dann ist es auch kein Verb. Also es ist einfach... Man denkt, kleiner Tipp an alle Physikstudenten, wenn ihr einen komplizierten Namen habt, lasst es. Nee. Lasst es.
So, es gibt, also keine Ahnung, Curie ist eine veraltete Maseinheit, aber ein Curie klingt gut. Klingt gut, kann man nur sagen, Curie. Ja, Planck, super, Planck-Konstante, perfekt. Ich glaube, Einstein hat nichts, aber dann irgendwie Heisenbergsche, Unschärfere, das ist alles zu kompliziert, wenn irgendwie Oppenheimer heisst oder so, raus. Git, Knipp, Bild, Bilb, Mnimb, Glemp. Mnimb, bitte auch nicht, wenn ihr Mnimb heisst. Ein Mnimb? Nee, bitte nicht. Das klingt gut. Röntgen auch bitte nicht. Röntgeröntcht. Geröntcht, na ja. Da ist alles falsch. Und dann schön mit dieser Bleischürze, schön im Genitalbereich. Stimmt, das wird sie draufgebeizt. Auch immer wird die auch immer zu doll drauf geworfen, wo die immer so ein bisschen zusammenzuckt, weil die auch alles schon gesehen haben und alles schon erlebt haben. Und ich war kurz davor, die wollte mir diesen Ländenschürz anlegen und ich so, können Sie nicht sparen. Wollen Sie nicht. Können Sie nicht sparen. Nichts wird passieren. Das ist, benutze ich so. Das kann doch nicht alles weg, benutze ich nicht mehr. Pass schon, pass schon, ich bin durch, habe ich hinter mir. Ah, macht Spaß, großen Spaß. Ah, du hast jetzt ein Kind. Diese Röntgenaufnahmen sind schon verrückt, da checkt man erst mal, was so ein Fuss eigentlich ist, das ist ja wie eine Hand. Meisterwerk. Also das ist ja wie eine flache Hand und du hast ja ganz viele Gelenke, also du hast ja in einem Finger hast ja drei Gelenke. Ja, wo man auch sagt, dafür kann man das echt schlecht bewegen alles. Super schlecht bewegen, ist alles zusammengewachsen, aber du hast trotzdem noch diese Gelenke. Ja, aber primär von den Nerven. Ja, und du hast gar keine Muskeln, glaube ich. Ich mache jetzt Sport neuerdings, schon ein bisschen länger, und da hat sich jetzt ein Trainer, der ist jetzt immer dann auch da, wenn ich da bin, und der macht mit mir immer Übungen. Das ist einfach ein ganz normales Fitnessstudio, ich weiß nicht genau, warum er sich, aber irgendwie, ich glaube, mitleid primär und hilft mir damit. Und der hat mir jetzt auch so Übungen gezeigt, die dazu da sind. Ich glaube, es ist alles eine Kopfsache, es ist alles eine Nervenbahne, die kann man sich ja wie Autobahnen vorstellen, auf denen, man hört auch in diesem Beispiel, dass es nicht von mir kommt, sondern von ihm, und die halt teilweise gut befahren sind, teilweise nicht gut befahren sind. Manchmal auch eine Raststätte haben. Oft Raststätten haben, ja, McDonalds dran ist. Wichtig ist die Sicherheitsschneise. Maut bezahlt werden muss auch. Und dann hast du halt diese Autobahn und du musst sie halt, du musst sie halt, und das ist da halt die Metapher dann auch auf Spaß zu machen, sie müssen voller werden, die müssen halt befahren sein. Stau, du brauchst Stau. Ja, deswegen meine ich, da hört es auf den Sinsel ergeben, aber du brauchst halt sehr viel Verkehr und die Füsse kannst du nicht bewegen gut, weil kein Verkehr, weil die Autobahn ist nicht befahren, die ist nie gelagelneu, aber halt unbefahren. Ist eine Landstrasse. Ist halt eine Landstrasse, ist eher gerade so ein ... Ist halt eine Fünfzigerzone. So ein Dorf, ist eine Flussgängerzone. Spielstrasse.
Ja, Spielstrasse. Ist halt eine Landstrasse, ist eher gerade so eine ... Ist halt eine Fünfzigerzone. So ein Dorf, eine Spielstrasse. Ja, Spielstrasse. Wie viel Zebrastreifen. Da funktioniert das noch nicht so richtig. Da flutscht der Verkehr nicht, deswegen kannst du die nicht bewegen. Ich glaube, das ist eine reine Kopfsache. Du kannst es mit einfachen Klopfübungen, also dass du dann, du kannst an deinem ... Ja, jetzt lach mal nicht. Bist du da keinem Sektenführer ange ... Ich weiß es nicht. Lächeln? Es ist vor allem immer so lächerliche Übungen, dann mache ich die auch immer nicht. Versucht er jedes Problem mit Klopfübungen zu lösen? Viel klopfen, ja. Wo klopft er dir hin, Stefan? Ich zeige dir drauf, da, also an Stellen, wo man nicht geklopft werden will. Aber manchmal will man da auch angeklopft werden. Aber er klopft dann, also zum Beispiel muss man sich hinten an der Wirbelsäule klopfen und dann muss man Kopfübungen, Drehübungen machen und dann weckt man die Nervenbahn, macht man dann, rüttelt man wach.
Ich gehe in eine ganz andere Richtung, ich will mit meinem Körper nichts mehr zu tun haben. Floating Head. Ja, wirklich Floating Head und man merkt auch erstmal, was man eigentlich für einen Quatsch alles hat. So, also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass wir irgendwie Genies sind und über den Dingen schweben, aber wir sind glaube ich schon Leute, die eher in geistigen Dingen uns bewegen. Also ich spiele Computerspiele, irgendwie lese ein Buch, also ich bin extrem faul, benutze meinen Körper wenig, das heißt ich habe wenig Kontakt zu meinem Körper. Das heisst, wenn ich dann mal so ein Zeh breche, wird mir erst bewusst, da sind irgendwie so kleine Stöcke drin und Äste und so kleines Zeug. Und ich habe mich wirklich geärgert. Ich habe mich geärgert, dass ich so einen scheiß Körper mit ihm rumziehe, jetzt da ins Krankenhaus fahren muss und nicht mehr, ich habe da Dota geschaut zu der Zeit, und nicht mehr Dota weiter schauen kann. Übrigens, herzlichen Glückwunsch auch an dich, OG, das Team OG hat gewonnen. Dankeschön. Ich habe die Doku geschaut, mir sehr gut gefallen. Eine ganz tolle Doku auf YouTube, könnt ihr gucken über Dota. Gibt es, glaube ich, auch eine neue Doku schon, weiss ich nicht genau. Also es gibt einmal TrueSide von dem Turnier letztes Jahr. Richtig, TrueSide. Und dann einmal Against the Orts, der ganze Weg so ein bisschen für, also wer weniger mit Dota zu tun hat, schaut sich eher Against the Orts an. Genau, da habe ich, ich habe das Spiel noch nicht verstanden hundertprozentig, habe dafür Spaß bekommen, jetzt mir das mal ein bisschen genauer anzuschauen. Auf jeden Fall eine ganz tolle Doku, wirklich, was eine fantastische Geschichte. Und was für junge Leute, die ja unfassbar viel Geld verdienen können mit diesem Sport, wo sehr viel, was sehr spannend zu gucken ist anscheinend, weil diese ganzen Teams ja mehr aus Freunden bestehen, die ja früher einfach zusammen dieses Spiel gespielt haben, auf Spaß. Und dann wurde es halt immer ernster und dann merkt man auch, okay, manche werfen ihre Prinzipien einfach komplett über den Haufen, einfach um da jetzt diesem Spiel erfolgreich zu sein. Ja, das ist ja so dieses Ding, dieses Team OG, da sind zwei gegangen, kurz vor dem grossen Turnier, um in einem anderen Team eine bessere Chance zu haben, das Turnier zu gewinnen. Genau, einer von denen war der beste Freund von dem anderen, von dem Teamcaptain quasi. Genau, und dann sind nur noch drei übrig geblieben und haben dann irgendwie das Team zusammengeflickt und haben die nächsten zwei Tier-Eis gewonnen, was noch nie jemand geschafft hat.
Und dann muss man ja die Leute, die das Team verlassen haben, denken sie, okay, wir verlassen das Team und danach gewinnt das Team zweimal in Folge den grössten Preis, den man gewinnen kann. Und dann gab es diesen tollen Moment, wo am Ende diese beiden besten Freunde, ehemaligen besten Freunde, dann gegeneinander antreten und ja das neue Team der Underdog gewinnt, was natürlich toll ist aus der objektiven Perspektive. Und dann gibt es diesen Moment am Ende, wo die sich die Hand geben müssen. Also ich habe selten in der Dokumentation einen so authentischen Moment gesehen, der wirklich total gruselig ist auch anzuschauen, weil du siehst einfach diese Erleichterung, diese Enttäuschung, also so eine komplexe, das kannst du einfach nicht spielen. In keinem fiktionalen Genre kannst du diesen Moment kreieren. Da siehst du einfach diesen komplexen Menschen mit komplexen Gefühlen und alle Emotionen und Informationen siehst du in seinem Gesicht, wenn er ihm diese, seinem ehemaligen besten Freund die Hand gibt. Das ist ein ganz irrer Moment. Also unbedingt anschauen. Das hat mir, auch als jemand, der keine Ahnung und da hat, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ja, es ist ja auch interessant, wie es weitergegangen ist. Das zweite Mal gewonnen hat noch nie jemand geschafft und es gab wieder auch natürlich wieder Spiele zwischen EG und OG, also EG, dem Team, wo der ehemalige OG-Spieler ist. Die Namen müssen dringend arbeiten. Sehr ähnlich. Es gibt EG.
Der eine heißt No-Tail.
Ja genau, No-Tail und Fly.
Will man nicht männlich sein?
Ja, der hat sich tatsächlich mal eine Zeit lang Big Daddy genannt,
aber ist dann wieder zurückgegangen zu No-Tail.
Beide Namen sind nicht optimal.
Dann hieß er Big Daddy No-Tail und dann wieder nur No-Tail,
weil er gemerkt hat, der ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu albern. Ich weiß nicht genau. Aber ja, auf jeden Fall tolle Spiele und das hat in China stattgefunden, das heisst, ich musste immer extrem früh aufstehen, um die Spiele sehen zu können live und hat alles durcheinander gebracht, aber hat auch Spaß gemacht, das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Werbung Was haben sie im letzten Jahr genommen, das weiss ich doch gar nicht. Weisst du, was dir helfen könnte? Ich habe die perfekte Idee für dich. Die TK-Save-Funktion deiner Techniker-Krankenkassen-App, die TK-App, die hast du kostenlos dabei, wenn du mit der Techniker-Krankenkasse versichert bist. Und da kannst du alles einsehen, das ist wie so eine digitale Krankenakte, du weisst genau, welcher Arzt, wann dich untersucht hat und was du für Spritzen bekommen hast, gegen was du geimpft bist, ja, du weisst alles. Es klingt wirklich absolut perfekt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich es mir gerade leisten kann. Das kann sein, wobei mir fällt gerade ein, sie ist kostenlos! Oh mein Gott, einfach die App überall runterladen, wo man sich Apps runterladen kann und die TK-Sale-Funktionen. Einfach überall runterladen. Sorry, ich bin ein bisschen zu aufgeregt, weil es so fantastisch ist. Nämlich ist sie aber wirklich kostenlos für jeden TK-Versicherten und dann einfach runterladen und dann könnt ihr da diese App benutzen. Ich fühle mich allein jetzt schon viel besser. Ich glaube dir das. Schreibt TK safe mit F und dann habt ihr es. Einfach bei Google TK safe, googeln findet ihr alles dazu. Findet ihr alles. Macht's gut, tschau tschau tschau. Viel Spaß bei der Folge, tschau. Werbung Moment, aber hat man manchmal. Oh, ich habe, mir ist es, also, ich muss mit dir, wir reden ja, es ist ja auch therapeutisch ein bisschen, mir ist diese sozial unglaublich unangenehme Geschichte passiert und ich weiß nicht besonderlich, wie ich damit umgehen soll. Folgendes Szenario, ich war abends, ich war am Geburtstag eingeladen vom Arbeitskollegen und bin dann relativ zeitlich nach Hause gegangen, weil ich am nächsten Tag früh aufstehen musste, weil es für mich zum Formel-1-Rennen ging. Ich weiß nicht, wer ist mein Formel-1-Rennen. So, das heißt, ich musste sehr früh, weil es war in Belgien das Rennen, da musste man ein bisschen hinfahren, deswegen bin ich sehr früh, wollte ich nach Hause, um dann früh schlafen zu gehen. Bin dann also zeitlich von diesem Geburtstag nach Hause gefahren und war dann bis dann zu Hause bei mir in die Wohnung gekommen. Jetzt habe ich schon ein paar Monate diesen Zettel im Flur hängen sehen, wo drauf stand, dass die Nachbarn sich alle unbedingt mal kennenlernen wollen, enger. Weil über die Jahre ist jetzt da eine Nachbarschaft zusammengekommen in diesem Haus, wo acht, neun Parteien drin wohnen. Niemand kennt sich so wirklich. Und ich muss sagen, ich finde das perfekt. Es gibt auch nichts Besseres, als einen Nachbarn nicht zu kennen. Ab und zu mal zu klopfen, weil man ein Paket will und das war's.
Ab und zu mal den Kratzeis rauszuholen.
Darüber hinaus will man noch nichts mit den Nachbarn zu tun haben.
So, jetzt haben die aber sich überlegt, na gut, wir machen das Riesenfest und alle Nachbarn haben zugesagt.
Und ich dachte mir, nein, du gehst einfach nicht hin und gut ist.
Habt es auch von vergessen, kommen dann aber wieder und viele wissen es schon, viele unsere Hörer, ich wohne im Erdgeschoss. So, jetzt haben die sich überlegt, im Garten zu feiern. Und zwar... Wenn man deine Wohnung kennt, ist es fantastisch. Direkt vor meinem Schlafzimmer stand der Tisch. Und die eine Hälfte hat direkt reingeschaut in meine Wohnung, die andere Hälfte saß wenige Zentimeter davon entfernt. Auf der Fensterbank stand der Lautsprecher, wo Musik rauslief, so eine rotierende Disco-Kugel, die meine ganze Wohnung erleuchtet hat. Pinnchen, Rum, Flaschen, Cola-Flaschen, alles stand da drauf. Ich komme nach Hause und meine erste Reaktion ist, mich flach auf den Boden zu legen, damit die mich nicht sehen. Ich habe kein Licht angemacht und das heißt, ich bin so, es war so halb elf, zehn Uhr, so und das war voll im Gange da draußen und mein Schlafzimmer war hell erleuchtet, wirklich, weil es draußen sind, da haben die auch Scheinwerfer aufgebaut und Lichterketten im Garten und so. Ja, die wollten sich immer so richtig schön kennenlernen. Feuerspucker, so Löhrer und der blöde vollidiot aus dem erdgeschoss ist halt nicht erschienen jetzt wollte ich aber dringend schlafen wenn ich in mein schlafzimmer gegangen wäre und dann bin ich in seiner kurzschlussreaktion in schlafzimmer gegangen ich dachte die sehen mich da nicht weil meine meine tasche da hingelegt und so und bin dann habe ich dann gesehen dass die mich alle gerade sehen könnten da bin ich wieder in die Hocke gegangen und bin so im Krieg, wie man das klingt aus so Bootcamp-Army-Filmen, bin ich dann so langsam in den Flur wieder, in Sicherheit, weil mein Wohnzimmer und mein Schlafzimmer waren dem Ganzen ausgesetzt, total. Also bin ich dann in den Flur gegangen. Meine Wohnung war stockfinster und ich dachte mir, was mache ich jetzt? Erst mal muss ich meine Tickets für morgen für das Formel-1-Rennen noch ausdrucken. Dann muss ich prima schlafen, mein Handy ausdrucken, äh, mein Handy aufladen, mehr muss ich nicht machen heute Abend mehr. Ich kann aber nicht in mein Schlafzimmer mehr, weil dann sehen die mich. Aber ganz kurz, wie ist deine Vorhangsituation? Vorhangsituation, ich habe keinen Vorhang. Du hast gar keinen Vorhang? Nein, ich habe Jalousien. Ah, okay. Und die sind außen am Fenster? Die sind außen am Fenster. Ich kann aber nicht. Ich kann denen aber unter keinen Umständen sagen, dass ich zu Hause bin. Weil, erst mal kann ich die Rollladen zumachen, weil die Fensterbank vollgestellt ist. Vollgestellt ist mit ganz vielen Sachen. Und die Bluetoothbox und all so einen Scheiss. Und deswegen, also unter keinen Umständen kann ich die Rollladen zumachen. Unter keinen Umständen kann ich Licht anmachen. Und dann stand ich da, wirklich, ich dachte, ich warte jetzt einfach, bis die Party vorbei ist, habe mich in meinen dunklen Flur gesetzt und so eine Stunde saß ich da und dann noch um mein Handy durchgescrollt, was dann irgendwann leer war. Aber ich dachte, was soll ich, was mache ich hier eigentlich? Ist das jetzt mein Leben? Ich bin sozial so in der Einbahnstraße gerast. Ein Fest, wo die sich, und ich kann ja auch nicht rausgehen noch und kurz Hallo sagen, weil ich das seit Wochen ignoriert habe. Und da war hier noch eine Liste im Treppenhaus, wo jeder aufgeschrieben hat, was er mitbringt. Und ich bring Salat mit, ich bring Würstchen mit. Nichts von mir. So, ich bin der Bösewicht in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Wie uncool ist das, jetzt da rauszugehen und zu sagen, sorry, ich, ähm, hi, ganz kurz, ich hab's vergessen, dass es heute stattfindet, ich geh jetzt rein und dann starb ich. Und ich mach die Rolle an und so, geht nicht, alles sagen geht nicht. So, Ende vom Lied war, ich habe mich dann, ich habe geguckt, wo kann ich mich hinlegen, wo kann ich ein bisschen Schlaf bekommen, weil ich muss ja morgen früh raus. Und dann habe ich, dann habe ich mir meine Decke vor meinem Bett gezogen, langsam, mit so einem langen Stock, mit so einem ganz langen Arm und habe mich dann ins Wohnzimmer geschlichen. Das Wohnzimmer war nicht so sehr betroffen, weil die saßen primär vor meinem Schlafzimmer. Wohnzimmer ist aber auch dem Garten ausgesetzt. Und dann habe ich mich ganz unters Fenster, habe ich meine Couch geschoben, dass sie unterm Fenster ist direkt. Das heißt, wenn man reinguckt, sieht man mich nicht. Und dann habe ich mich ganz nah ans Fenster gelegt und dann Decke drüber. So, dann habe ich halt da versucht zu zu schlafen und das ging dann auch so ein bisschen gut, es kam noch sehr viel Disco-Licht rein und so weiter, ging dann aber ganz gut. Und der Rauch vom Grill direkt. Direkt rein, reingeballert und dann irgendwann, habe ich ein bisschen aufgewacht, weil die Party sich aufgelöst hat und dann habe ich nur, da haben die aufgebaut und die dachten halt, ich bin nicht da, weil alle Fenster waren offen und so weiter, nichts an der Wohnung gesagt, dass ich da bin, Gott sei Dank.
Und dann haben die aufgeräumt und dann haben die irgendwie so Tische zugeklappt und so und halt an das Fenster gelehnt, wo ich gerade war und dann bin ich aufgewacht und so. Also es war so knapp, also haben die auch teilweise reingeguckt natürlich.
Dann habe ich auch so, weil dann war es auch dunkel draussen, dann haben die die Schellwaffer abgebaut und danngebaut und haben mit dem Handy den Garten abgeleuchtet und haben noch Sachen rumliegen und dann sah ich immer so das Handylicht durchs Zimmer huschen bei mir und dachte mir, ja klar, die stellen direkt davor und natürlich gucken die mal rein. Und dann lag ich halt so unter dem Fenster und ich dachte mir, wie unangenehm, weil ich habe immer rausgeguckt, mit offenen Augen und lag dann da so ruhig, wie unangenehm wäre das jetzt, wenn jemand reingeht in den Zimmer und Augenkontakt mit mir hat und der Nachbar den Nachbarn sieht, der mit offenen Fenster da schläft und sich offensichtlich versteckt und hofft, dass es vorbei ist. Auf seinem Sofa schläft, unnötigerweise. Und mit so grossen Augen da steht und ganz ruhig sich bewegt und dann hätte ich auch so Gleise gegrüsst, hi, hat alles funktioniert, ich wurde nicht entdeckt, aber wirklich so drei Stunden meines Lebens habe ich mich vor meinen Nachbarn verstecken müssen. Ja. Unglaublich, was eine blöde Situation. Wie gut, aber ich glaube, ich hätte es exakt genauso gemacht. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich versucht, in der Küche zu schlafen, oder in die Küche bist du ja gut reingekommen. Ja, die kann man gut reingekommen. Hätte man da schlafen können, in der Küche kann man nicht schlafen. Kältester Raum, unangenehm. Alle anderen, also meine Küche ist ja so komisch gefliesst. In der Badewanne vielleicht? Habe ich auch darüber nachgedacht, lange ja. War lange im Gespräch in meinem Kopf, dann rausgeflogen gegen die Versteckaktionen im Wohnzimmer. Keine Chance, Folgen zuzuziehen, keine Chance, Rollen runterzumachen. Also alles daran war maximal blöd. Aber es ist ja auch so maximal ungünstig, dieses Zimmer genau voll. Also allein die Vorstellung, dass die dann eine Party feiern und immer wieder in ein Zimmer schauen, wo jemand zum Beispiel auch nur am PC sitzt, alleine oder so. Und halt diese awkward Situation, du hast ja so ein soziales Treiben und so und direkt daneben, nur durch eine Glasscheibe abgetrennt, sitzt da jemand und schaut dann irgendwie YouTube an oder so was. Ja, ich hätte das vergessen, das habe ich vorher die Rollladen zugemacht und so. Und das war wirklich sehr unangenehm. Habe ich dann überstanden. Und dann habe ich es da schön vor dem Lines geguckt. Aber tatsächlich eine Gewohnheit, die dir geholfen hätte, die ich habe, ich mache immer die Rollladen zu, wenn ich mein Haus verlasse. Ah, okay. Immer. Hätte mir geholfen, ja. Obwohl ich im dritten Stock wohne. Aber ich habe irgendwie
Angst, dass das Sonnenlicht irgendwie meine Sachen
ausbleicht. Ist total
irrational, ist total Bullshit.
Du bist wirklich, habe ich auch schon noch erzählt,
einer der unmaterialistischen Menschen, die ich kenne.
Du hast keinen Bezug zu deinen Dingen.
Du bist Dingen keinen Wert
bei. Aber irgendwie habe ich keinen
Bock, dass Sachen... Aber hast du Angst, dass die ausbleichen?
Ich will nicht, dass was ausbleicht. Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, irgendwas ist das bei mir. Und deswegen mache ich immer die Roller anzu, bevor ich gehe. Und was dann manchmal zu ulkigen Situationen führt, weil dann ist es halt stockdunkel. Und ich mache dann halt in stockdunkelheit muss ich noch meinen Rucksack packen und so. Ich mache es mir selber sehr schwer. Du machst es mir sehr schwer. Aber das stößt man sich schon mal den Zeh an. Könntest du dir vielleicht auch angewöhnen, immer die Roller anzu machen,, bevor man das Haus verlässt? Im Eidgeschoss wird dich nicht so trivial. Damit sowas nicht mehr passiert. Die Chance ist sehr klein, dass sowas nochmal passiert, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich werde das wahrscheinlich trotzdem jetzt machen, weil das ist wirklich unangenehm. Du kommst hier, ich bin mir noch nie so böb vorgekommen, wie zwei Stunden lang in einer stockdunklen Wohnung zu sitzen und zu warten, dass die fertig sind mit Feiern. Und sie so die Zeit zu vertreiben, mit auf Handy zu gucken und so.
Also ich konnte eigentlich mal in mein Zimmer reingehen, in mein Buch rum, man hat nämlich ja gesehen.
Es war wirklich einfach zum Vergessen, diese Situation. Ganz seltsam.
Vor allem, also ich meine, ich hatte immer eine ähnliche Situation, also ähnlich unangenehm und komme auch auf eine Situation.
WG, Party, WG-Mitglieder machen alle eine Party im Wohnzimmer, alle cool dabei, irgendwie Musik, wunderbar, du alleine in deinem Zimmer schläfst und merkst irgendwann, du musst aufs Klo.
Und ich muss durch das gesamte Wohnzimmer durch, um zum Bad zu kommen.
Oh Gott.
Und ich habe mich den Leuten nicht vorgestellt, ich wurde nicht gefragt, ob ich auch auf diese Party will, nichts, gar nichts, die wussten nicht, dass ich da bin. Wenn jetzt die Tür aufgehen würde, furchtbar. Und ich dachte mir, was mach, versuche ich einzuschlafen und ich meine, es geht nicht, ich muss, ich muss aufs Klo und irgendwann denkt man sich halt, ja, ich habe auch ein Fenster. Nein! Und man überlegt halt Dinge.
Man überlegt Dinge.
Man ist halt plötzlich mit sich allein man wird auch plötzlich kreativ so das sind so diese MacGyver Momente weil man überlegt wirklich welche Auswirkungen weil du weisst die offensichtliche Lösung die jeder Mensch wahrscheinlich machen würde kannst ich kann ich nicht machen und dann fängst du an out of the box zu denken und dann fängst du an the box zu denken und dann denkst du dann halt, okay, jetzt dieses Fenster, die Idee gefällt mir, aber wie genau machst du es? Wo hast du denn gewohnt, in welchem Stock? Auch im dritten, auch im dritten. Und es war halt so unangenehm, weil ich dachte mir so, das ist halt, direkt aus dem Fenster, es geht jetzt in eine sehr unangenehme Richtung, direkt aus dem Fenster würde halt zu lange dauern. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja. Ich weiss nicht, sind da Leute unten, wie sieht's aus, was passiert? Ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, es darf nicht lange dauern, es muss eine schnelle Aktion werden. Also in die Flasche erst und dann auskippen. Ich hatte eine Cornflakeschüssel stehen. Nein. Und ich dachte mir, für die Situation optimal. Schnell ausschüttbar, grosses Fassungsvermögen. Ich habe kein Gefühl dafür gerade, wie viel der Menschliche Körper, wie viel die Blase eines männlichen Körpern. Das ist ein sehr, sehr gutes Argument der Ratize. Ich dachte kurz, reicht die Schüssel? Kommt auf die Schüssel an. Kommt auf deine Blase an. Ich habe eine sehr kleine Blase. Und eine sehr kleine Schüssel. Und eine sehr grosse Schüssel kommt auf die Schüssel an kommt auf deine Blase an ich habe eine sehr kleine Blase und eine sehr kleine Schüssel und eine sehr grosse Schüssel und ich sage mal so dein Argument war nicht schlecht die Schüssel hat nicht ganz gereicht ich musste noch auf dem Glas ausweichen und dann halt so wirklich und dann denkst du dir wirklich dann bist du auf so einem animalischen Niveau du machst Dinge da bist du nicht stolz darauf klar bist du nicht stolz darauf und dann ist es auch so dieses muss man sich immer die Hände waschen? Warum? Und normalerweise wäscht du dir immer die Hände. Du stellst Dinge in Frage, Dinge, die für festgaben. Ja, und du hast ja auch so konditionierte Gefühle. Wenn du aufs Klo gehst, dann fühlen sich deine Hände schmutzig an. Obwohl die ja eigentlich nicht schmutzig sind. Das ist genauso wie, wenn du ohne die Zähne zu putzen ins Bett gehst. Das ist ja nicht schlimm, wahrscheinlich, aber es fühlt sich falsch an. Und genauso fühlt es sich falsch an, da liegst du im Bett und denkst, hast eh gerade das Schlimmste gemacht, du hast das Fenster aufgemacht, Schüssel raus, egal was da unten ist. Menschen hört sich. Und du hörst halt von unten nur so ein Watsch und denkst dir, ach. Wo war das Fenster raus, war das zum Garten? Das war ein Innenhof. Okay, gut. Also geht noch, geht noch. Innenhof. Aber da standen halt auch Fahrräder unten und so. Es ist alles ganz schrecklich. Es ist alles ganz frisch. Ja, ich weiß. Und dann liegst du im Bett und denkst dir, ach man, ey. Ich bin da echt nicht stolz drauf, aber es ist so, du kannst das nicht. Aber wie sehr du es jetzt zu schätzen wissen musst, einfach aufs Klo gehen zu können. Ja, total, alleine wohnen ist das Schönste. Aber ich glaube, wie toll es war für mich, dann wieder reinzugehen in mein Bett und die Rollladen zuzumachen, weil sie dann weg waren alle. Besseres Gefühl gibt es gar nicht. Und in deiner Situation, das erste, was ich mir gedacht habe, also ich kenne jetzt deine Wohnung nicht exakt und weiß nicht genau, wie das mit denen, aber ich dachte mir, kann man die Rollladenen nicht ganz langsam runter machen. Die saßen halt wirklich Zentimeter von dem Fenster entfernt. Aber als du gesagt hast, dass auch die Box so steht, dass es die Rollladen nicht ganz runter geht, dachte mir eh Gameover. Aber ich dachte, kannst du in einem Moment schnell hinhuschen und dann so ganz langsam, weil du hast ja Zeit, also wenn du da zwei Stunden sitzt. Es sind aber auch nicht diese diese schönen Lamellen, ne es sind einfach diese Raps-Rolläden, die hätten sich über die Musik hinweg erschreckt, was da gerade passiert wäre, die wären alle zusammengezuckt.
Weil wenn du weisst ja, also es gibt ja so Momente im Leben, wo Dinge passieren und du weisst, okay, ich werde mich jetzt erstmal die nächsten Stunden mit diesem Problem beschäftigen müssen. Und das ist ein Gefühl der Entspannung. Also genau wie bei meinem Ze so, du denkst dir Fuck, Schmerz, ah, fuck. Und dann realisierst du, okay, das nimmt jetzt den Rest meines Tages ein. Krankenhaus, Betäubung, Medikamente. Wann ist das passiert, abends oder? Vormittags. Wie gesagt, chinesische Zeiten, Achtung, vormittags. Und du meistst einfach, okay, das ist jetzt einfach mein Tag. Und dann bist du ein bisschen entspannter, weil du weißt, okay, Tag ist eh gelaufen, egal. Und in dem Moment, wo du merkst, okay, ich werde Stunden investieren müssen, die Situation zu regeln, hätte ich mir gedacht, ich kann auch eine halbe Stunde investieren, um ganz langsam die Rollladen drin zu machen, so über eine halbe Stunde hinweg. Langsamer. Und dann, wenn jemand auf dieser Party ist, ist so voll an so ganz langsam.
Und irgendwann, wenn sie dann zu sind, hat sie immer gesagt, war die Roller nicht voll auf. Die war doch auf.
Vor einer halben Stunde. Ach, furchtbar. Das war wirklich, also das war so schrecklich und man denkt einfach, also man kommt sich auch so lächerlich vor. Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, das kennt man ja auch, ich denke an so Leute, die ich bewundere, sei es Prominente oder Freunde, mit denen man gut ist oder die man cool findet, Mentoren. Und man denkt immer, was würden die jetzt machen? Und ich konnte nichts Souveränes vorstellen. Mit der Vorgeschichte, mit den Nachbarn, ich bin auf keine bessere Lösung gekommen, als unter dem Fenster auszuharren, bis sie weg sind. Unglaublich unangenehm, sehr unüblich. Also ich meine, du bist ja anscheinend jemand, der gut schlafen kann, auch bei Lärm und Belästigung und so, ich ja gar nicht, das heißt für mich ist, ich hätte die einzige Möglichkeit wäre gewesen, rauszugehen und es ist alles unvorstellbar, wissen wir alles, aber jetzt mal nur als Theorie, rauszugehen, zu sagen, ah, guten Abend, ich bin hier aus dem Erdgeschoss, eine Sache, ich habe morgen einen Termin in Belgien, können Sie vielleicht die Boxen ein Stück zur Seite rücken, dass ich die Rolladen runter machen kann?
Und können Sie die Lärmbelästigung auf ein Minimum reduzieren? Dankeschön. Nicht nur bin ich bei der Party nicht dabei, sondern ich rufe auch die Polizei. Ich denke mir halt nur, das ist das schlechteste Zeichen, diese Rabatz-Rolläden, genau, es ist das unabhängige Geräusch für ein und dann für eine Belehren uns alle mal kennen Party, das schlechteste Zeichen, nach außen hin. Ungezwungenes Kennenlernen, ist aber ein guter Soundeffekt, das sollte man häufiger verwenden, so als Symbol für, ich will nichts mit dir zu tun haben. Ja, dieser typische Rollladensound.
Aber Rollladen ist bei mir wirklich im Rückenmark, ganz, ganz tief, weil wir fahren jedes Jahr Campen und da gibt es immer so die Besitzerin des Campingplatzes und die wohnt direkt neben unserem Platz. Und wenn wir nachts zu laut sind, dann macht die die Rollladen hoch, um das Fenster aufzumachen und rauszuschreien. Und über die Jahre hinweg hat sich dieses Ritual reduziert auf, sie macht nur die Rollladen hoch. Und wir wissen alle, wir sind sofort still und sofort Musik aus, Feuer aus, alles aus. Und das ist so geil, weil sie auch weiß, welche Macht sie hatten, nur mit diesen Rollladen. Wie toll, wie freundschaftlich dieses ja eigentlich auf Sankt gebaute Verhältnis muss man ja sagen. Aber wie schön ist es ihr euch so angenähert habt, dass noch das nötig ist. Ja, dass eine Form von Kommunikation entsteht. Und irgendwann ist es nur noch so ein so ein kurzer Lichtschalter. Und die sieht schon, oh, aus. Ne, das ist auch gut. Ne, finde ich super. Ja, dann war ich in Belgien, habe zuerst mal Formel 1 geschaut. Aber das ist wirklich, du hast es vorher auch schon gesagt, in Privatgesprächen haben wir darüber gesprochen, macht es so viel Sinn, Formel 1 live zu gucken? Nein, alle zwei Minuten und dann wartet man halt zwei Minuten und dann fahren sie wieder vorbei. Man kriegt nichts mit vom Rennen, alle Sachen, warum ich Formel 1 spannend finde, Strategie, Boxenkommunikation, Wetter, macht alles nicht so viel Sinn. Ja, ist schon auch cool, wenn du weisst, du hast ja diesen Regenradar, dann siehst du bei den Teammonitoren, wann gleich Regen kommt und dann überlegen die mit Boxenstops und Reifenmanagement. Kriegst du alles nicht mit, weil du einfach da sitzt und siehst dich vorbeifahren. Und dann siehst du dich vorbeifahren in leicht anderen Reihenfolgen, weil irgendwo ein crazy Überholmanöver war in einer Kurve, in der du nicht sitzt. Du siehst ja nur eine Kurve halt. Und ich habe auch in einer Kurve gesessen, wo kein Überholmanöver jemals passiert ist in dem Rennen. Dann war auch eine sehr schlechte Stimmung, weil einen Tag vorher, auf der schrecklich jemand gestorben ist, in der Formel 2, ganz, ganz unangenehme Stimmung. Aber ein Fahrer oder ein Fahrer ist gestorben bei einem Unfall, ganz, ganz schlimm. Und dann war die Stimmung auch nicht so gut. Aber Highlight des Tages war Frank Zappato, Zappata, der Typ auf dem Flyboard, den wir beide so toll finden, ist vorbeigeflogen.
Er war die Fourband, er war Teil des Fourprogramms.
Frank Zappata ist mit einer, ich glaube aber wegen des Todesfalls, mit einer italienischen, mit einer französischen Flagge, ist er über die Strecke geflogen einmal. Der Typ ist ja abgestürzt neulich, er wollte den Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Erbel-Er000 Menschen einfach am Rand und gucken das Formel-1-Rennen, wenn er einfach so lang fliegt, auf seinem Flyerboden einfach wuuuuh, ist ungefährlich. Aber es ist wirklich das Nächste, was wir an einem Superhelden haben, Frank Zapata, weil ich denke mir auch so Frank Zapata in seinem Zapata-Turm und dann so Monsieur Zapata, in Belgien ist ein Formel-2-Fahrer gestorben. Kein Problem, die brauchen mich jetzt. Er fliegt da hin, ich kümmere mich drum, ich kümmere mich drum, wenn mein Board aufgelandet ist. Vor allem so, ich glaube, die brauchen jetzt, was diese Menschen jetzt am ehesten brauchen, ist ein fliegender Mensch auf einem Board. Ist die Flyboard-Armee Frankreichs, sie. Ja, und dann ist er losgeflogen und hat einmal die Strecke in einem unglaublichen Tempo überquert, wo man auch sagt, davon will ich gerne Rennen sehen. Ja. Ich will lieber Frank Zapata sehen. Drei-dimensionale Rennen sind generell interessanter. Du kannst auch überfliegen. Das Beste ist ja, der ist ja irgendwie siebenfacher Jet-Ski-Weltmeister, muss man auch mal sagen. Und er hat gesagt, jeder kann siebenfacher Jet-Ski-Weltmeister und kann deswegen auch wahrscheinlich gut auf so Boards fahren, schätze ich mal. Und der hat gesagt, das kann jeder lernen, das ist kein Problem. Er ist gerade der einzige, der das Board fliegen kann, das kann aber jeder lernen, dauert halt nur sieben Jahre. Nein, aber in sieben Jahren ist Frankreich wahrscheinlich so eine Weltmacht, der man nichts mehr anhaben kann. Ja, aber in sieben Jahren holen alle auf. Die nächsten sieben Jahre dominiert Frankreich alles, aber dann hat der erste Pole so ein Board gelernt, weil er hat ja sieben Jahre Vorsprung vor allem. Die können ja jetzt erst anfangen. Ne, genau. Aber es ist schon ein souveräner Vorsprung, muss man sagen. Ah, was für ein geiler Satz, einfach. Wie so ein Konzertpianist. Jeder kann das so spielen wie ich, wenn man 30 Jahre trainiert. Aber jeder kann das. Das könnte jeder. Man muss nur siebenfahrer Jet-Ski-Weltmeister sein und acht Jahre trainieren, jeden Tag. Jet-Ski-Weltmeister. Alter, was ist das? Gibt es da eine Biografie zu fragen? Zapata, Alter, das das der interessanteste Mensch aller Zeiten. Beim Namen fängt es ja schon an. Können wir den einladen? Ja, es wäre mir egal. J'arrivé? Niemand spricht auch nur ein Wort Italienisch. J'apprends le français et je dire le français avec Frank Zapata. Je ne parle pas français. Ich muss sagen, ich sage so gut den Satz, je ne parle pas français, dass Leute mir nicht abkaufen, dass ich kein Französisch spreche. Weil ich denke mir auch, diese paar Worte, die du kannst, die muss ich auch gut sprechen, ist aber nicht gut. Man sollte das nicht gut sagen. Ja, das ist ganz wichtig. Das war tatsächlich das, was ich mit meinem Französischunterricht gelernt habe. Ich kann kein Französisch sprechen, aber ich will, wenn der Lehrer mich fragt, übersetzen Sie mal, will ich souverän ablehnen können. Ja, ich will souverän sein, wenn ich es gerade nicht kann. Genau, deswegen habe ich gelernt, je ne le se pas, je ne se pas und aucune Idee, um auch ein bisschen variieren zu können, damit ich nicht immer dasselbe sage. Ist halt zu kreativ, um dem Lehrer das Gefühl zu geben, dass du gerade wirklich nicht kannst, oder eher so eine Faulheit spricht ja eher dann aus dir. Ja, aber dann sagt der Lehrer, sagt ja, komm, mach mal. Aber Lehrer mö mögen Arrogant. Lehrer mögen Arroganz. Wenn sie das Gefühl haben, der schreibt eine Sechs nur, weil er sich nicht anstrengt, kriegt er eine Vier. Na gut, du bist durch die Schulzeit gekommen. Naja, vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Ja, besser muss man sein. Alle Lehrer da draußen, bestätigt das mal. Ich glaube, so vor allem dieses, für mich können Sie mal setzen, Je ne le seps. Aucune Idee. Dann nehmen wir jemanden an. Nee, okay, passt, reicht. Reicht. Reicht. Reicht. Wenn die St reicht reicht wo die stimme zusammenführt reicht reicht alles in ordnung ja dann war ich in belgien mal eben war auch seltsam ja und abends war ich wieder in köln einfach kurz ist wirklich nicht weit weg weil man fällt eigentlich nur anderthalb stunden dahin und dann ist man wieder da und dann war das in den ardennen das rennen war in den Adennen, man ist eben in den Adennen,
und dann weiß ich nicht wusste nicht genau, was die Adennen sind, aber es ist primär ein bergiges,
bergige Wälder mit sehr vielen Schafen und Kühen und dazwischen ist halt eine Rennstrecke, Spa,
und da sind die ganzen Autos gefahren, das war echt, echt underwhelming, aber auch cool.
Aber Adennen ist doch spannend, du hast endlich den Deutschen durchgekommen, Zweiten Weltkrieg, Erster Weltkrieg.
Die Adden sind spannend, nee, ich meine das Rennen war nicht so spannend.
Die Adden an sich sind cool.
Haben die dann die Rennstrecke hingebaut, falls sie nochmal angreifen, dass sie dann zu Puffer haben?
Abgelenkt sind, abgelenkt sind.
Zwei Stunden, Leute, wir müssen hier weiter.
Warte, warte, warte, warte.
Schnell, was ist das denn?
Odoren, Odoren.
So sprechen Soldaten für dich. Odoren, Odoren. Wo ist Odoren, du? Wie sollen denn sonst sprechen? Das sind normale Menschen. Das sind Soldaten. Ja, nee, das ist völlig richtig. Soldaten können ja jetzt kostenlos Bahn fahren. Hast du das mitbekommen, die Debatte? Ja, und viel Spaß beim Karneval. Jeder Zweite als Soldat verkleidet ist. Oh ja. Ist beim Karneval nicht eh alles egal. Aber hat man als Soldat auch so eine Art Ausweis oder so? Aber so wie ich es verstanden habe, dürfen die umsonst fahren, wenn sie ihre Uniform tragen. Okay, dann können sie ihre Uniform kaufen. Genau wie sich ein Kollege zu Karneval einfach ein Pfarrerkostüm bestellt hat, aber halt nicht im Kostümladen, sondern bei einem Pfarrersupply.
Aber das ist doch eine Strafbar, oder?
Du darfst doch, wenn du kein Soldat bist, darfst du keine Uniform tragen.
Oder ist das nicht so Amtsanmassung?
Aber ist das ein Amtssoldat?
Es ist auch Blasphemie, wenn du das machst.
Ja gut, aber da kommst du in die Hölle, aber nicht vor das Amtsgericht.
Hast du mehr Lange vor dem Amtsgericht oder vor der Hölle?
Vor dem Amtsgericht, wie tief.
Dann heißt es, ja, wir bräuchten die Geburtsturkunde.
Und ich so, ach, sperren Sie mich ein, ohne Witz. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich überhaupt geboren wurde.
Sperren Sie mich ein.
Aber Soldat ist kein Amt, oder?
das vor der Hölle. Vor dem Amtsgericht, wie tief. Und dann heißt es, ja, wir bräuchten die Geburtsturkunde. Und ich so, ach, sperren Sie mich ein, ohne Witz. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich überhaupt geboren wurde, sperren Sie mich ein. Aber Soldat ist kein Amt, oder? Es ist nichts, was man, keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber, ähm. Naja, du hast auch andere Rechte, oder nicht, als Zivilisten. Aber ist es nicht ein großes Problem, weil wenn sie ihre Uniform tragen, dann sieht man sie nicht mehr? Kann man die nicht kontrollieren? Ich meine, die konnten bis jetzt ... Dieser Feueralarm? Okay, raus hier, raus hier! Ich meine, die konnten bis ... Burn! Nee, stimmt schon, man sieht die ja nicht mehr. Aber so eine krasse Scharfschütze-Tar-Uniform und einfach so Morgan, Morgan. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum die so Zugfahren in dieser Uniform. Oder warum die nicht diese Musterung der Bahnsitzer haben? Weil, mal ehrlich gesagt. Das ist doch jetzt mal ein Post. Das ist mal ein Tweet. Die Bahn veröffentlicht, die Bundeswehr veröffentlicht ihren Bahntarnanzug einfach so als Dankeschön ihren Bahntarnanzug. Weil diese blaue Musterung, diese Tarnarnanzug. Ja, der Gag funktioniert, weil alles sich reimt auch leider. Aber das wäre doch mal was, wenn wir diese typische blaue Musterung der Bahnstühle hätten. Das stimmt schon, das stand es sich. Finde ich sehr gut. Aber alle Uniformen dann oder was? Also auch Marine und so und auch Flugzeuge? Das weiß ich nicht. Luftwaffe? Heißt das noch Luftwaffe? Nee, Navy und Air Force. Ja, aber die Deutschen. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Luftwaffe. Ich glaube schon Luftwaffe, oder? Kann sein, ja. Marine? Deutsche Luftwaffe und Marine. Aber ich finde, alle Uniformen sollten, was heißt Uniformen, auch so Arztkittel, Krankenschwesterkittel, alle Leute, die einen Job machen, Feuerwehrmann, eigentlich alles, was eine Uniform trägt, sollte sonst fahren dürfen. Ja gut, aber jetzt, wo fängt ein Uniform an und wer jetzt auf? Jetzt ein Geschäftsmann im Anzug. Ist das nicht auch eine Art Uniform? Nein. Nein. Ich glaube, es ist sehr deutlich die Filter, was eine Uniform ist. Ich dachte mir einfach... Du wolltest einen sozialkritischen Kommentar machen. Oh, ist unser Äusseres nicht eh alles eine Uniform? Versuchen wir uns nicht alle, eine Normativität unterzuordnen. Ja, ja, kennen wir alles. Wir haben alle dein Scheißbuch gelesen, Stefan. Ja. So, ich muss los. Du musst nach Hamburg. Ich wünsche dir eine gute Reise. Ich habe mich gefreut, mal wieder mit dir zu sprechen. Dankeschön, ja, das war unsere Sommerpause übrigens, zwei Wochen Sommerpause. Jetzt machen wir drei Wochen Sommerpause. Nein, jetzt geht es einfach ganz normal weiter. Ganz normal. Bis es wieder aufhört. Vielen Dank für das Intro, von wem auch immer das Intro kam, vielen Dank und haut rein, wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche wieder, macht's gut, wir sagen
tschüss und heben ab, ciao!